non
[Musique]
oui les aménagements vert mais surtout
c'est que maintenant les gens se
connaissent moi j'aime le fait qu'il est
souvent des activités
tête à créer des liens entre les besoins
t on une petite campagne balladur par un
beau samedi 2 mai nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de l'udc corbin de sa famille
et de ses voisins ensemble ces résidants
de rosemont petite patrie à montréal ont
décidé de changer leur milieu de vie
en s'offrant une ruelle verte est ce que
tu vas dit oui à quinze mille abeilles
il ya une seule règle c'est ce qui est
fascinant la reine ce qui arrive aux
vices de 3 5 ans tandis que la b movies
35 jours c'est une journée bien spéciale
pour les résidents de la rue elle la
compagnie alvéoles installe une ruche
sur un toit du garage au grand bonheur
des petits et des grands
vous avez une super belle reine textron
elle s'appelle gignac
lorsqu'on pense ruelle on imagine de
l'asphalté des voitures des ordures et
des graffitis
on n'avait pas vraiment le réflexe de
jouer dans la rue est de toute façon on
est mal à lui resté pratiquement
dangereux parce que comme ici au sud les
voitures passer mais de plus en plus de
citoyens comme l'udc et andré malaquais
décide de verdir et d'embellir leur
ruelle pour en faire un espace de vie
pour amorcer le processus
ils ont contacté leurs écoquartier
d'arrondissement cantons le parti projet
ya trois ans on s'est mobilisé d'un
groupe peu près vingt neuf personnes y
fait beaucoup autour de l'âne raisons
sécuritaires
c'est beaucoup d'enfants dans la ruelle
et avait bien évidemment tout
l'argumentaire autour de contrer des
sojas l'air d'amener des espaces
avertissement et la ruelle verte aide
aussi l'environnement en améliorant la
qualité de l'air la biodiversité et la
rétention des eaux de pluie on vient
jouer un rôle si tu veux à notre mesure
au niveau des changements climatiques ça
fait partie des mesures d'adaptation que
je crois que des citoyens doivent
prendre dans leur engagement social
ça appartient à qui on commencé gérer
les placements balafon l'êta de bande de
c'est un principe de parrainage est dans
le fond où chaque locataire ou
propriétaire pour décidé de parrainer la
demande devant chez lui la première
année on ne sait ce que kim pas une de
cette murale ça c'est super coup parce
qu'elle va nettement cette zone là
c'était des poubelles et des graffitis
puis ça fait trop avec un que la murale
et peint les politiques effectives mais
une seule visite et on comprend qu'au
delà de la verdure qui prend sa place
c'est l'aspect humain qui en ressortent
gagnants c'est ça c'est la vie
communautaire sacré et li ning claire
m'a peut-être créer un espace commun des
changes mais humain qui seule clé de
davantage de pouvoir se parler discuter
échanger que les enfants jouent et
malade est encore humide qui s'épilent
it et c'était vraiment à montréal c'est
dangereux
attention aux enfants vieillissante et à
chaque fois qu'ils me rendent des
outaouais on peut laisser sortir c'est à
lui que lui tend même à 14 ans fait pas
son exploit - quand j'étais jeune dans
un petit village
[Musique]
la rue elle devient le théâtre d'une
foule d'activités rassembleuse à
l'halloween la rue elle est envahie de
zumbi et de sorcières un attrait pour
tous les quartiers tu es à la louis
n'ont fait une rue malartic dalphond à
la place que tout le monde donne des
bonbons
chacun chez soi on se met en commun on
annonce de grosses marmites de bonbons
on y organise aussi des projections de
films extérieur la décoration d'un sapin
de noël et la traditionnelle cabane à
sucre
les résidents de la rue elle pousse
toujours le projet un peu plus loin
après les abeilles viendront les poules
on désire construire plus à y est et on
va toucher une partie de mon père et non
je suis très d'accord pour que ça
devienne un outil d'éducation pour les
enfants les familles un point de
rencontre également le nombre de ruelles
vertes est en forte progression à
montréal en cinq ans on est passé de 123
environ 350 ruelles vertes
c'est presque le triple chacune de ces
ruelles à sa personnalité propre
avec ses plantes ces murales ces espaces
de jeu et sa vie communautaire et ce ne
sont pas que les jeunes familles qui en
bénéficient c'est agréable espace commun
favorise le rapprochement
intergénérationnel
ce qu'on souhaite c'est que des
personnes âgées dd fait participer des
sorties de leur milieu je pense qu'on a
le devoir leurs citoyens aujourd'hui une
autre activité est au programme la
création et l'installation de pancartes
au nom des enfants est une autre
occasion pour nous de constater
l'entr'aide et les liens qui se tissent
dans cette fête cette communauté
finalement le concept de ruelles vertes
pourrait très bien contribué à retenir
les jeunes familles en ville parle
beaucoup maintenant de l'exode des de
montréal si je pense qu'un bon exemple
de ce qui peut être une utilisation de
terrain pas d'accord mais reste prêt de
faire en sorte que ça puis bénéficier à
tout le monde dépendent je pense que
c'est sur la rue aylwin c'est l'esprit
de communauté à la fin les caves à sion
les plans c'est le fonds nécessaires
c'est le fil conducteur qui nous a
rassemblés pour évoluer vers d'autres
chose de plus grand
[Applaudissements]